Shut up and let me respond.
>> Respond to the argument then. Go ahead.
>> Shut up and let me respond. I will say
whatever I want. You are not in charge.
>> Respond to the argument.
>> You are not in charge. Shut the hell up.
>> Why are you crashing out? Just answer.
>> Shut up. You are not in charge, man.
>> Go ahead.
>> You ask me one question, I will respond
as I wish. Your religion is not in
charge here. We are not your demies.
>> You did not answer that Jesus is the son
of God.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masjid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000 and believe me if every single
one of us give £1,10,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makayama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds and your
makama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
>> Yeah. So, uh, who do you believe
authored the Quran?
>> Muhammad and his friends.
>> Okay. So, do you believe it's one voice
or multiple voices?
>> It is unsure. Uh, I would say that it
might be it was probably very much based
on Muhammad, but then um his scribes and
others may have contributed to it and in
some points he might have listened to or
he might have been influenced by others.
For example, you have you have a hadith
where where Omar says that Allah agreed
with him on on several occasions because
Omar made suggestions then they appeared
as Quran verses. So it is probably
Muhammad but also influenced and
contributed to by his followers and
friends.
>> Okay. So so again like you know I'm
being clear. So is it one voice and he's
just borrowing ideas from people around
him or is it multiple voices? Very
simply just yes which one is it? Just
quickly
>> I'm not sure how to make it clear. Um,
it might have been primarily Muhammad,
but others may have contributed to it.
>> But is it one voice? I don't know what
you mean by being very vague. Is it one
voice of the Quran and he's just being
influenced or is it multiple voices?
>> I don't know. It might have been
probably it was probably primarily
Muhammad who is making up the narrative,
but it was probably him also getting
ideas and messages.
>> So, one voice. It's one voice getting
from other people but it's also later on
others contributing to it because as as
we know and as Muslims often actually do
not really understand the Quran itself
never became a a complete text in
scripture in the time of Muhammad only
after Muhammad died and after the battle
of Yama a lot of people uh were killed
of the scribes and the memorizers of
Muhammad's followers came together to
compile the Quran and and and there was
a discussion of wait a minute Muhammad
himself never suggested this but then we
should do it anyway. So we don't know
what happened in that process. Others
may have corrupted or or contributed to
it. I don't know.
>> Yeah, it's a red herring. So just
styometric studies
>> this is literally
>> because styometric studies alone have
proven that there's one author. Badam
Sedi says that the semantic content and
the style patterns are consistent.
There's only one author.
>> So
>> okay uh it can't be one author.
>> So who's so who's that one author? Tell
me.
>> Muhammad. But here's the issue. This is
why I'm pointing.
>> Okay. Wait, wait, wait, wait. I'm I'm
here. I'm here to exam you. You gave me
your answer. You said Muhammad. But let
me let me ask you.
>> So, Prophet Muhammad is the author. Is
Prophet Muhammad illiterate or he knows
how to read and write?
>> What?
>> Is he illiterate?
>> I don't know. Uh, the Quran says that he
is un
>> everything you don't know. Can you give
me an answer?
>> If Islam is true, why did God kill
Muhammad for lying about him by sending
a Jewish woman with a sacrificial lamb
which killed him?
>> Yeah. So, you guys believe that your God
literally died? He literally died on a
cross humiliated and you're bringing up
like, "Oh, why would God allow the
prophet sallall alaihi wasallam to die
like a martyr?" Dying as a martyr is
something that's honorable. And I have a
video debunking um this whole claim that
the prophet Muhammad wasallam is
therefore a false prophet linking to the
hadith about it and the Quran verse. So
yeah, you can check on my channel for
that.
>> Well, here's the here's the interesting
contrast. So Muhammad himself actually
makes the claim or the Quran says that
if if he presented false would kill him.
Um whereas in in Jesus in Christianity
there is such a saying in Christianity
we acknowledge that actually the beauty
of Christianity that God himself Jesus
himself uh takes on flesh and becomes
one of us and is not a tormentor like a
lot of Islam becomes one of us and takes
us takes our hands and uh and leads us
to salvation together with him. That is
the ultimate sacrifice and the ultimate
love of God which you of course don't
have in
>> that's why Jesus said God God why have
you forsaken me?
>> Yeah because it's a prophecy which you
would understand if you had read the
Psalms.
>> It's typology. It's not convincing at
all. You're saying that's a prophecy but
you don't grant Psalm 72. That's clear
hypocrisy. David is saying in the psalm
about his condition in his time period,
there's no indication at all that this
is talking about a future event using
typology. Again, this is nonsense. So,
if you you accept that as prophecy, but
you don't accept that Psalm 72 fulfills
the prophet.
>> I hope you guys enjoy the video, guys.
But before that, please download the
Salah Pro app. Brothers and sisters, we
are a charity. All of our services on
the app is for free. Free kibla finder,
no ads, free salah reminders, encourages
to pray, tells you salah times. You can
book a salah instructor, a Quran
instructor. You can order a guided
prayer map for absolutely free if you
want to learn how to pray salah. Videos
on how to pray salah salah hubs and many
many more brothers and sisters. We are
not an app that shares your information
with third parties. All of our services
on the app is for free. Download it now
inshallah and enjoy guys. Let's go back
to the video.
>> Crystal P says the vineyard represents
Israel, the people of God.
>> No, the tenants. No, no, no. You said
yes, but it's not. The tenants represent
the Israelites. the vineyard represents
the kingdom of God. So I don't even know
what he's trying to say there, but he
misunderstood the parable.
>> But the entire thing is about Israel.
The entire thing is about the people of
God. The vineyard is Yeah. But he said
about is about the the people of God. So
uh when Jesus talks to the Jews, he's
not talking about some about some randos
600 years later or 700 years later. He's
clearly talking to Jews. uh speaking to
speaking to Jews in a way that Jews
would understand and that uh he when
when speaking of the parable. This is
directly this directly corresponds with
uh the Jews in charge rejecting his his
message and putting the son of God to
death and then the focus shifting from
Israel to the uh the Gentiles. This is
the popular narrative. This is because
it is exactly how it happened.
>> Yeah. You didn't address the temple
destruction as my rebuttal to that. the
temple destruction happened after after
the preaching to the Gentiles.
Ridiculous after the pre after the
preaching to the Gentiles, the temple
happened. The par the parable's
chronology isn't that way. You didn't
respond. You can say it's irrelevant,
but you're not responding.
>> I'm absolutely a propagandist for Israel
because I love Israel and I want people
to know that that uh the truth about
Israel. But Sam Shimon definitely not.
So
>> listen, is Israel is the same country
that quotes biblical scripture like 1st
Samuel 15:3 to justify the the genocide
of the Palestinians. I don't I don't
know which Christian would would
actually support such a nation and
actually and actually and actually claim
to follow Jesus. Just believing
believing in that scripture itself
>> is uh is outrageous.
>> That's not what happened. Unless you
want to claim that Hamas are all
Palestinians because it was specifically
for Hamas. But uh if you want to go
ahead and claim that all Palestinians
are Hamas, then that's on you.
>> It's first Sammy 153 genocidal.
>> Completely off topic.
>> Truth Seeker says question.
>> Can you show Dean Sahi Albukari
7498?
How it quotes Paul's 1 Corinthians 2:9
says, "Can you show Dean Paul was a
messenger according to Muslim sources?"
>> Yeah. Well, first of all, I have to say
I have to point out um it doesn't really
matter who quotes Paul and who doesn't
quote Paul. It is very very firmly and
clearly established that Jesus entrusted
Peter and his disciples with his
message. His disciples directly worked
together with Paul. Paul affirmed
everything Jesus taught and worked
together with the apostles. If Muslims
claim to respect Jesus, they should also
respect Paul and his writings. If they
if they uh do not respect Paul and his
writings, then they do not respect
Jesus. End of story.
>> So this is apparently from uh first
Corinthians, right? The prophet sallall
alaihi wasallam said, "Allah said, I've
prepared for my righteous servants,
slaves, such excellent things as no eye
has ever seen, nor ear has ever heard,
nor a human heart can ever think of."
Now uh this Christian uh that postulated
that is copying from Paul uh doesn't
know that this is already a saying from
Jesus within the gospel of Thomas a
saying gospel that scholars date to the
first century scholars that date this to
the first century a saying of Jesus
where he talks about the god will give
you stuff that you never seen never
heard etc. So he's just assuming with
his Christian lens that it has the
source has to be Paul when in fact the
just not just the Quran but the hadith
is at interplay with sayings of Jesus.
>> This is from Isaiah. It is it is a very
well-known.
>> No no no it's not. So this just show me
your ignorance of Isaiah because Isaiah
doesn't quote it this way. Isaiah
>> I know but it's a but it's a reference
to Isaiah.
>> Okay. So so does Isaiah have some does
he say there's something that you've
never heard never seen that you're going
to be given? Does it say that?
>> It not literally. It's it's it's just
reference to Isaiah. That's what I'm
saying.
>> It it doesn't say it. Jesus expands upon
the saying in Isaiah and adds these
details of no eyes have ever heard, no
um eyes have ever seen. So this the
saying in Isaiah just says that um a
diff like a whole different context
while Jesus expands with it.
>> Yeah. So So you you see how Yeah. So So
you see one you're laughing now. So
because you surprise Yeah. So, so you
tried to say this hadith isn't with
trying to disrespect. I mean, this just
a clown show.
>> No, that just cut me completely.
>> And who you are? You're like you're like
you're like snorting like why are you
laughing? So, knowing this, we can now
make the case for Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in Psalm 72.
We have the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam ruling from east to
west. This is fulfilled within Psalm 72.
This individual also will prohibit
usery. It says he shall redeem their
souls from usery and injustice. What we
also have is that he'll be gifted golds
of Arabia. He shall be prayed for
continually and there will be continuous
praise for him. Also the Gentiles will
be blessed through him. Obviously as
Jews already themselves, the prophet
Muhammad sallall alaihi wasallam
preaches the same God that they preach
and he had them and the prophet Muhammad
sallall alaihi wasallam had the Gentiles
know the one true God through his
message. Well, do you do you pray to
Jesus or do you pray for Jesus? That's
all like you can give him his time now.
>> Okay. So, uh Pharisees don't exist by
the way. Pharisees were the group that
existed before the rabbitic Jews came
into existence.
>> But um anyway, uh when it comes to Psalm
72, yeah, I don't know why you why
you're why you're smirking. This is
literally facts. Psalm 72. Uh I'm not
sure if we're at the cross- examination
section, but as as as said, uh the verse
is literally about uh about messianic
prophecies and about the lineage of of
of David and about the people of Israel.
It has nothing to do with Muhammad at
all. So,
>> okay. So, he didn't answer my question.
Uh I didn't ask you that. I asked you if
uh you pray to Jesus or do you pray for
Jesus. Um so yeah, I'm just going to
continue on that point because you just
chose not to answer. So if you believe
that Jesus is God, then you don't pray
for him, you pray to him. Okay? So this
prophecy says that you will pray for
this person. Okay? Your rebuttal was
extremely weak. I'm giving you a great
rebuttal that you you you don't pray uh
for God, you pray to God. your was oh it
says it's a king and uh look at the rest
of the psalms well the thing is it
mentions a king sure but you know even
early church interpretations like totian
this is uh the king is the person being
prophesied while the son is his nation
there's interpretations like the church
gives you um as well as the fact that
prophet Muhammad sallallaihi wasallam
was a king of Arabia so essentially so
he still fulfills it in that sense
there's no indication that this is about
the messiah
>> that's very Funny because um because as
as it seems uh this can be interpreted
in any way possible uh as the
interpreter likes to. Uh so if if in the
future um a different person comes and
then fulfills uh vaguely apparently some
of these things while completely failing
others. Very simply you're you're saying
conquering from east to west is like
something that's so easy. I can just
make a religion. We can conquer from
east to west as we like it. Conquer
Russia, conquer the United States. We're
done. Like this is not easy. conquering
Rome and Persia at the time as a small
group is something that's unspoken of.
So this is not just something that's
easy. Prohibiting usery as well that's
there's incentives to have user within
society. That's why you even find
Christians today a lot of them don't
even prohibit user. They allow it. They
do it. So it's not easy. Second uh
thirdly actually we have the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him being
blessed. His name being someone that's
continuously praised and he is
continuously praised every single day.
Who fulfills that criteria? There's more
than just a couple of these vague.
You're trying to say it's vague when
it's not. It's very hard to fulfill.
This isn't something that's very easy.
As well as uh finally there's a
reference as inference as this person
being a descendant of Ishmamail going
back to Genesis where it says this
person will bless the nations. The
prophet Muhammad is a descendant of
Ishmamail. So there's so many
requirements are needed in Psalm 72. The
prophet fulfills it. You need to appeal
to the future for Jesus to fulfill it.
>> Uh I have a very very simple question
for for Dean here. Um, and it's just
ridiculous that we keep standing on
this, but um, could this could this
prophecy also apply to the Soviet Union?
>> What,
bro? What are you talking about, man?
>> Who sings the Soviet Union's praise? Is
the Soviet Union a descendant of Abraham
where he's going to bless nations and
bless the Gentiles? Like, does this do
they fulfill all these requirements? Did
they even conquer from east to west? Why
Why are you getting red for it?
>> Yes, they actually did. I have you ever
seen a Have you ever seen a map of the
Soviet Union at the greatest extent?
Like the Soviet Union banned usery,
right? The Soviet Union actually banned
usery. They they ruled over the greatest
uh over the greatest
>> Who prays for them every day? Who prays
for them every day?
>> They had a um they had they had marches
and hymns that are still widely
widespread that are still sung across
across different
>> Are they from the descent of Ishmail?
Are they
>> don't like them? But but still well um
well their culture certainly comes from
a descent. There is literally zero zero
chance zero possibility that Paul acted
completely on his own without the
approval and the collaboration of these
others. The early church was united in
what they did and uh and Jesus entrusted
them with what he what he left them and
Paul was thereby by extension a disciple
and apostle of Christ.
>> Yeah. So, so where does uh where does
Clement or Polycarp or Ignatius uh talk
about Jesus being God in a nian
trinitarian sense?
>> I can quote it quote it to you right
here.
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> 2,000 years later,
>> the sources are for for Ignatius uh his
letter to the his epistle to the
Magnesian. It already starts with um so
uh the father, son, and holy spirit. He
says uh to Jesus Christ the son uh
through the father and the holy spirit.
This is directly in the the epistles. Uh
Maggesians 13:1-2
says, "Be zealous then to be firmly
grounded in his ordinances of the Lord
and the apostles." It continues with the
faith of
>> Are you are you going to like spam
quotes? Like how many quotes are you
going to give? I'll ask for one quote.
So
>> you just asked where do Ignatius and
Clement of Rome affirm uh the
trinitarian beliefs or the the beliefs.
>> Okay. So So that's for Ignatius. Huh?
Magnesian epistle to the Magnesians in
the Son and the Father and in the Spirit
in the beginning and in the end. This is
literally found in the epistle to the
Magnesians which is also here once
again.
>> I've read it. Yeah. Yeah. No problem. I'
I've read I've read.
So So the epistle So the epistle to the
Simansians I have it right in front of
me. So just share my screen real quick.
>> So this is so funny. You ask me where
they affirm these beliefs and I give
them to you and then you want to move
on.
>> Yeah. Because uh I'm I'm telling you
that you're wrong because I'm sharing my
screen right now. So as you can see this
is the letter to the Sony chapter 1. He
says Jesus uh if we just read the
context here Jesus Christ both in flesh
and spirit and are established in love
through the blood of Christ being fully
persuaded with respect to our Lord that
he was truly the seed of David according
to the flesh
>> and the son of God according to the will
and power of God. So do you believe do
you believe that Jesus don't interrupt
me. Do you believe that Jesus is the son
of God according to the will according
to the will of God or do you believe
Jesus is the son of God necessarily? So
>> these are different ideas. Uh when he's
when when when he is it says to the seed
of David, it is clearly talking about
his human nature his humanly state. So
when when Jesus comes uh and takes on
flesh, he is by the will of God uh
directly in the flesh in the seed in the
flesh the son of God according to the
will and power of God. This is very
>> No, right there it says son of God. You
No, you just deceptively baited and
switched because the first part
the first part says truly the seed of
David according to the flesh and his
divinity his son of godship traces back
to the will and power of God. God has
free will. Therefore, if he's doing
something by his will, he could have
chosen otherwise. Therefore, Jesus
begotten.
So now you want to So now you want to
say now you want to say that uh that
that he always was independently and
necessarily the son of God. Yet you just
asked me if Ignatius and Clement of Rome
affirmed that uh that they also believe
that Jesus is the son of God and that
that that in or that God is father, son,
and holy spirit. Do you acknowledge that
God is father and son and holy spirit
according to Ignatius?
>> No. I just I just explained to you just
went over your head basic philosophy. If
something is done by the will of God,
then he could have chosen otherwise.
Could Jesus not be begotten?
>> Okay, I'm asking you. I'm asking you the
question.
>> Could Jesus be begotten? Could Could
Jesus not have been begotten? Yes or no?
>> I'm asking you the question here. Uh,
did Ignatius according to your text?
>> I asked you can't answer a question with
the question. I just asked
>> Did Ignatius believe that that Jesus is
the son of God?
>> I I already said no, bro. I already said
no. Now answer my question. Did he
believe Jesus was the son of God?
>> Right here. It literally says
>> he says according to the will of God.
That means it's not a necessary.
>> He's talking about he's talking about
about Jesus Jesus in the flesh which is
why it precedes
>> doesn't say the flesh. It says son of
god is is Jesus as the son of god uh
talking about the flesh. No it's not.
He's making distinction between the
flesh and between the son of god. Son
son son son son son son son son son son
son son of David being human son of God
meaning he's divine in some sense but
yet he's still begotten by the will of
God. So God could have not begotten
himself.
>> I I did answer the question that you go
and pose. You ask me one question, you
leave it at. You are not in charge here.
Listen, we are not your demies. You are
not in charge here.
>> You are not in charge here, man. You are
not in charge here. Shut up and listen.
When intelligent people are talking, you
asked me one question. I answered your
question and you move the go ahead.
>> Okay, here I will give you I will give
you a response. Number one, Muslims are
not the kings of the world. You are not
the demies. You are not in charge.
>> Shut the hell up and listen what I'm
talking.
>> Why are you playing a victim? Can you
can you respond to the argument?
>> You just said you will let me respond.
Shut up and let me respond.
>> Respond to the argument then. Go ahead.
>> Shut up and let me respond. I will say
whatever I want. You are not in charge.
>> Respond to the argument.
>> You are not in charge. Shut the hell up.
>> Why are you crashing out? Just answer.
>> Shut up. You are not in charge, man.
>> Go ahead.
>> You ask me one question, I will respond
as I wish. Your religion is not in
charge here. We are not your demies.
Shut up and learn to listen. You are
people of are of low intelligence which
is why all you know is to explode
yourselves and to cry and keeping you
shut up. Shut up and listen. You are not
in charge.
>> You did not answer that Jesus is the son
of God according to the will and power
of God. You try to link this back to the
flesh point. I told you no. The son of
godship is about the will and power of
God. You don't believe Jesus is the son
of God according to the will and power
of God. You believe it's necessary. God
has free will. If it's by his will, that
means he could have willed otherwise.
That means it's not necessarily
necessary sunship that the father begot
the son. Very simple.